all right we have ted florendo standing
by with your forecast and of course
you've noticed it when you've been out
and about that air quality has been so
rough lately the past couple days it's
really lingering but still managed head
over your left shoulder to get this
beautiful sunset one thing though the
haze does do is give us great sunset
shots right it's there we got that
outside right now wish that haste could
just go away completely but with those
fires going on brian that not going
anywhere in fact right now we still have
that air quality advisory in effect
smoke advisory all the way through
friday but again great sunset shot here
we posted this on our social media so
you can share it all with your friends
and family maybe your in-laws too
104 degrees are high for the day today
102 are average all right so we're above
average the record on the state 111 set
back in 2011. currently outside it's
still warm out there out there 98 for
summer 102 for satunda hills uh right at
the century mark for alliante 104 for
downtown 104 sunrise manor 104 for green
valley and whitney ranch 103 henderson
and at the central mark for you to
rhodes ranch mountain's edge as well 96
for indian springs 109 for laughlin 800
for for you're joining us from boulder
city all right radar network we had
those brief and i'm talking brief and
isolated light showers sprinkles this
morning all right came up in the
colorado river and that was it not going
to get any tonight not going to get any
tomorrow but we still see some storms
that are still firing up out there you
know grand canyon west now rain chances
this weekend nil nothing however we will
start to see the monsoon start to sneak
its way back up it is monsoon season
still all the way until we get to mid to
late september
increasing those chances again on monday
around the region it all depend on this
too this is tropical depression 14e okay
so here's cabo right here
14e
is down uh just south of puerto vallarta
and what's going to happen is this could
send some tropical moisture away we're
gonna have to watch that and if it does
send us some tropical moisture that will
increase our chances for storms around
the region right now it just bears
watching 82 degrees overnight hazy skies
breezy at times for this evening 106 for
tomorrow hazy and hotter tomorrow this
is above normal and we will keep around
some of those breezes too here your
neighborhood behind neighborhood
temperatures 114 hills mountains edge
including north las vegas 107 104 also
for henderson outside the valley here
you go prompt 103 104 boulder city and
114
for laughlin for tomorrow your eight on
the eight day forecast shows
temperatures giving close to records
again not going to reach them we think
at this point nice over the weekend
we'll drop those numbers a little bit
and then next week the numbers drop
however the humidity goes up and there's
our storm chances for early on next week
that is your most accurate forecast here
on eight news now